this morning we are in great sorrow and
pain said marseille's mayor on Twitter
on Monday morning in the early Sunshine
a digger continued the work of clearing
Rubble is
fireman told us that there is still hope
and that we'll find victims alive so
we're continuing the rescue operations
as we started them last night slowly
step by step not to hurt people that
could still be alive
Witnesses say they heard a loud
explosion and a smell of gas in the
early hours of Sunday morning it brought
down two buildings and parts of another
on Route Italy in central Marseille
several people were taken to hospital
with serious injuries
evacuations started immediately and
continued into the daytime
we heard an explosion between midnight
midnight and 1am a very strong one that
made us jump we looked out the window to
see what was happening and we saw Rubble
smoke and people shouting
Rescuers continued their efforts
throughout Sunday France's interior
Minister came to see and spoke of the
challenges
it is very difficult to access since the
rubble has covered almost all of the
fire and of course the rubble must first
be removed safely for firefighters to be
able to intervene nor can we intervene
in a normal way since if there are
survivors the water or the firm used by
the firefighters could prevent them from
surviving
eight people were killed in Marseille in
2018 when two dilapidated buildings
caved in Aid agencies reported at the
time that forty thousand people in the
port city were living in substandard
structures
but City officials have ruled out
structural issues in this latest
collapse Rory challenge Al Jazeera